[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله معكم محمد مزيم
الزوان ونستعرض معا ابرز اخبار الاسبوع
الماضي بايجاز وفي نشرتنا قمه عربيه في
جده بمشاركه بشار الاسد جوله الانتخابيه
ثانيه لاول مره في تاريخ تركيا مانشستر
سيتي وانتر ميلان في نهائي دوري ابطال
اوروبا اضافه الى اخبار اخرى نتابعها سويه
هيا بنا
قمه عربيه في مدينه جده السعوديه بحثت
القضيه الفلسطينيه والازمه السودانيه الى
جانب ملفات اقتصاديه اخرى كما شارك فيها
الرئيس بشار الاسد لاول مره منذ اندلاع
الثوره السوريه وتجميد عضويه بلاده في
جامعه الدول العربيه وكان لافتا ايضا حضور
الرئيس الاوكراني زميلنا عثمان فرح تابع
القمه من هناك
يا مرحبا عثمان
ما ابرز ما ركزت عليه القمه العربيه في
نسختها الثانيه والثلاثين نعم تؤتي مجال
القمه العربيه في جده هذه القمه العربيه
الثانيه والثلاثين بالموافقه على الاعمال
ومن اهميه التاكيد على مركزيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه على اهميه العمل على ايجاد
تسريع
كما تم تاكيد على
اهمتها وجميع المناسبه لعوده اللاجئين
السوريين
الخارجيه في الشؤون العربيه ورفض تدخل
الخارجي في شان السوداني الذي قيل انه من
شانه ان يؤجل الصراع وعلى ان اللقاءات بين
الفرقاء في جده قدوه يمكن البناء عليها
واكدوا كذلك على احترام ثقافه وقيم
الاخرين واستعمال ووحده وسلامه الاراضي
لكافه الدول شكرا
الى القدس حيث شارك الاف المستوطنين في
مسيره الاعلام بينهم وزيره الطاقه والامن
القومي واعضاء في الكنيست وقد اقتحم مئات
المستوطنين المسجد الاقصى المبارك تزامنا
مع المسيره الفلسطينيون تعرضوا لقمع قوات
الاحتلال والمستوطنين في منطقه باب العمود
والبنده القديمه بينما انطلقت مسيره عن
الحدود في قطاع غزه رفعت فيها العلم
الفلسطينيه ردا على مسيره المستوطنين وقد
اطلقت عليها قوه الاحتلال القنابل الغاز
والرصاص المقاطي مسيره الاعلام جاءت بعد
اسبوع من التصعيد والقصف الاسرائيلي على
قطع غزه قام خلاله الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
باستهداف قاده من الجهاد الاسلامي معي
الاستاذ ناصر الهدمي رئيس الهيئه المقدسيه
لمناهضه التهويد مرحبا استاذ ناصر
ما الذي تعنيه خطوه مسيره الاعلام وما
الذي يريد الاحتلال تحقيقه من خلالها في
تقديرك تنظم السلطات الاحتلال في كل عام
مسيره الاعلام لتكون رمزا على سيادتها
وسيطرتها على المدينه المقدسه بشطرها
الشرق والغرب الا ان السلطات الاحتلال
استطاعت ان ترسل رسائل مفادها انها لن
تنساها لتهديدات المقاومه وان مدينه القدس
تحت سيادتها وسيطرتها وان المعادله
الجديده لن تكون مقبوله لديها معادله
المواجهه الا ان سلطات الاحتلال لم تستطع
ان تثبت ما ارادت ان تثبته هذه المسيره
وكانت هذه المسيره بكل ما كان فيها من
جنود وتحويل للمدينه الى سكنه عسكريه اكبر
دليل على ان سيادتها في المدينه منقوصه
وان هناك من ينازعها هذه السياده لذلك
نقول نعم ربما تكون قد مضت هذه المسيره
الا انها لم تثبت ما اريد لها ان تثبته
شكرا جزيلا لك الاستاذ ناصر الاحد الماضي
شهدت تركيا انتخابات رئاسيه وبرلمانيه
بمشاركه قياسيه تجاوزت
88% ولقيت اهتماما عالميا واسعا وفي حين
نجح تحالف الجمهور الحاكم بحصد اكبر عدد
من المقاعد في البرلمان لم ينجح اي مرشح
رئاسي بجمع اكثر من 50% من الاصوات ما
يعني التوجه الى اجراء جوله ثانيه لاول
مره في تاريخ تركيا سيتنافس فيها الرئيس
اردوغان ومنافسه كليجدار اوغلو اللذان حصد
اعلى نسبه من الاصوات سالناكم على صفحه
الجزيره في تويتر من تعتقدون انه سيكون
رئيس تركيا
القادم لنرى سويه الاجابات حتى موعد تسجيل
ايجازنا الاسبوعي
88%.7 قالوا رجب طيب اردوغان بينما قال
11.3% منكم كمال في الجدار اوغلو
هجوم صاروخي مكثف على اوكرانيا هو التاسع
خلال هذا الشهر وكيف اعلنت اسقاط معظم
الصواريخ التي استخدمت في الهجوم سلطات
القرن المواليه لروسيا اوقفت العمل بخط
لسكك الحديديه بعد خروج قطار شحن عن مساره
كيف اعلنت ان الخط المستهدف كان لامداد
القوه الروسيه بالعتاد وقد شددت موسكو
انها لن تترك ذلك دون ردد بينما اوضحت
بيانات جديده ان الجيش الروسي استقطبعه
عشر الف جندي جديد منذ بدايه العام وكشفت
تسريبات ان الدول الغربيه بصدد تزويد كييف
بمقاتله اف 16 الامريكيه الى السودان حيث
قصفت مقاتلات الجيش السوداني مواقع لقوات
الدعم السريع بالعاصمه الخرطوم قائد
والجيش البرهان اقل حميتي من منصبه كنائب
لرئيس مجلس السياده وعين الفريق اول شمس
الدين كبا غائبا له بينما قالت مصادر
الطبيه ان عدد الضحايا منذ بدء المواجهات
ارتفع الى اكثر من 830 قتيلا ونحو 3000
وخمسمائه مصاب الاشتباكه بالاسلحه الثقيله
بين الطرفين تزامنت مع استمرار المحادثات
غير المباشره في جده في الرابط ادناه
تجدون فيديو يتحدث عن بنود اتفاق جدا
مانشستر سيتي يتاهل لنهائي دوري ابطال
اوروبا لكره القدم للمره الثانيه في
تاريخه بعد فوزه العريض على ضيفه ريال
مدريد برباعيه نظيفه في اياب نصف النهائي
كما تاهل انتر الايطالي على حسابي جاره
ميلا
وسيتوجه الفريقان في المباراه النهائيه
التي ستحدد الفائزه بدوري الابطال وتقام
على ارض ملعب اتاتوركا الاولمبي في
اسطنبول لدي دقائق قليله قبل ان تبدا
النشر الرياضيه على الهواء استغل هذه
الفرصه ليتوجه لزميل عمار نامق الذي يستعد
لبدئها مرحبا عمار عندي سؤال المليون
دولار
من في تقديرك سيكون الفائز بلقب دوري
ابطال اوروبا محمد كمنطق قد لا يختلف احد
على افضليه مانشستر سيتي في هذه
المباراه المباراه مباراه على شكل بطوله
بطوله من مباراه واحده تبدا من صفاره
البدايه وتنتهي عند تتويج الفريق الفائز
لماذا هذه طبعا نحتاج لها التحليليه وليس
ايجاز لكن هناك هناك مثلث جدا مهم التحضير
البدني التحضير الذهني وخطه المدرب التي
ستكون الى ابعد درجه صحيحه لانه ليس هناك
مجال للتعويضي مباراه وحده فقط كلها تدخل
هذه العوامل في تحديد الفريق الفائز ولكن
ربما الابرز بانها ستكون حتما فرجه كرويه
وفنيه بكل تاكيد حتى ان بالنسبه لجمهور
الاوروبيين اهم كثير من الجماهير
الاوروبيه تعتبرها اهم من بطولات من
مباريات كاس العالم الحديث معك عن عمار
شيق ولكن لا اريد ان اسمع صوت المخرج
وموديل الاستوديو
من الان شكرا لمتابعته نلتقي بحول الله
الاسبوع المقبل شكرا محمد السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]